1497 and the British Empire didn't exist
neither did Britain England was the
largest and most powerful country in the
British Isles at this time Wales the
Isle of Man and the peace of Ireland
could the pale were firmly under English
control the rest of Ireland was mostly
independent only giving lip service to
the English monarchy and in the north
Scotland remained independent a close
ally of France King Henry the seventh of
England wish to improve England's
trading situation the English were not
exactly renowned sailors at this point
and so Henry did what everyone else did
at the time hired an Italian a certain
Giovanni kobato
kobato was searching for a northern
route to China but landed in North
America becoming the first European to
set foot there at least since the
Vikings had five hundred years earlier
Henry the seventh continued the long
tradition of English monarchs and died
before being succeeded by his son Henry
the eighth Henry the eighth contributed
to the expansion of English holdings by
incorporating Wales into the kingdom of
England and giving it representation in
Parliament
in 1534 Henry split with Rome creating
the Church of England which would begin
the religious divide between England and
Ireland eight years later he had himself
declared the king of Ireland although in
reality this didn't change very much
Henry was succeeded by Edward and
shortly after that came Queen Mary the
first a Catholic who married king philip
ii of spain one important part of mary's
rule with the beginning of the irish
plantations which sure lands belonging
to irish law was confiscated and given
to the English for settlement Mary and
Philippe never had children and so after
Mary's death in 1558 the crown passed to
her sister Elizabeth because the English
Parliament made sure Philippe was
ineligible Elizabeth was a devout
Protestant and reinstated many of her
father's laws which punish Catholics
much to the anger of Philip who saw
himself as the defender of Catholicism
Spain held the Netherlands at this point
and the northern part which is a large
Protestant population was rebelling
against Spanish rule England was more
than happy to help undermine Spain's
power and one way the English helped the
Dutch was by giving Dutch privateers
shelter in English ports so privateers
were essentially pirates who had the
protection of a government and Elizabeth
employed many Spain had a growing
colonial empire at this point and there
was a lot of trade particularly in
silver between Spain and its colonies
privateers would seize this cargo by
raiding Spanish ports and ships before
taking it back to England the most
famous of England's privateers is Sir
Francis Drake who conducted numerous
highly profitable raids against the
Spanish he also circumnavigated the
globe and even claimed land
what is now California beyond private is
England also sent explorers to the new
world such as Sir Walter Raleigh who set
up a soon to be mysteriously abandoned
colony at Roanoke Island in North
America Elizabeth also continued Irish
plantations to shore up the English
position their exploration and
colonization at this time was almost
always reliant some royal patronage in
order to get funded English Spanish
relations were not improved by England's
moves across the Atlantic since been
claimed nearly all of the new world and
also losing silver was presumably not
much fun for Philippe either relations
worsened when Portugal England's oldest
ally had a succession crisis which saw
Philippe crowned its king the final
straw for Philippe was when Elizabeth
had Mary the Queen of Scots beheaded in
1587 the reasons for this are complex
but it was essentially because Elizabeth
did not want Scotland returning to
Catholicism so Philippe now pretty fed
up ordered the creation of an armada
which was to sail to the Netherlands
before invading England when the Amada
reached England several skirmishes
occurred the most famous being the
Battle of the Gravelines were an English
victory forced the Spanish fleet to sail
around the British Isles in order to
return to Spain storms a lack of food
and disease caused thousands on the
return journey in this failure pretty
much bankrupted Spain the next year
England chose to counter-attack and
launch the English Armada under the
command of Sir Francis Drake the goals
of the Armada were to destroy the
remaining Spanish ships the revolt in
Portugal and intercept any Spanish
Silber so the English Armada was a
complete failure and cost the lives of
thousands of English sailors and was
very expensive it did however guarantee
that England would remain independent
towards the end of her reign Elizabeth
made one last contribution to the Empire
and founded the East India Company which
was given a monopoly on trade with India
Elizabeth died childless in 1603 and was
succeeded by James the sixth of Scotland
who was crowned James the first of
England changes early reign saw the end
of the war with Spain and was marked by
several attempts to kill him most
notably the Gunpowder Plot James
contributed to the empire by sponsoring
colonial ventures he sponsored another
way for plantations in Ireland most
notably the Ulster plantation which
contained many Scottish settlers
alongside English ones
James also oversaw the first permanent
English settlement in the Americas the
colony at Jamestown next was Bermuda
followed by Plymouth which was famously
founded by the Puritans who arrived from
the Mayflower
so Jamestown was founded by the Virginia
Company of London with the goal of
making its shareholders a profit the
colony was famously led by John Smith
who maintained good relations
with the Native Americans Smith was
forced to return to England after being
injured in a gunpowder explosion and
4-time relations between the English and
the natives remained peaceful these good
relations wouldn't last and soon the
English and natives were fighting and
after several wars the English managed
to push the natives out of the area in
order to grow the cash crops on which
the colony relied indentured servants
were imported in this context indentured
servants were people who sold themselves
into a form of servitude for a period in
order to pay for their voyage to the New
World
indentured servants were soon replaced
with slaves from Africa since there was
no obligation to free them and they were
easier to obtain Indian raids against
the colony and rebellions against
neglectful rule made it very difficult
to make a profit and the colony was
turned over to the English crown there
were many reasons for colonial expansion
there was a strong desire to proselytize
and convert the natives of the new word
which many believed would civilize them
some undertook extremely expensive
voyages of discovery but the most common
reason was money Spain and Portugal had
amassed huge worth trading with their
colonies in China and England didn't
need much convincing cash crops such as
tobacco and sugar were extremely
profitable and even more money could be
made on the return voyages via the sale
of slaves to the new world the Atlantic
triangle is his home another reason was
security the money from trade as well as
large overseas populations loyal to the
crown provided extra manpower and money
for Wars to support the slave trade
England established forts along the
coast of Africa from which they operated
trading goods for gold ivory and people
slaves from Africa were also much easy
to obtain them the indentured servants
which came from England Ireland or
Scotland this was because of the
numerous major upheavals across the
British Isles such as the English Civil
War which saw the British Isles briefly
become a republic under Oliver Cromwell
the Irish capitalized in a weakened
English state and broke away from
English rule Cromwell brutally and
swiftly put down these rebellions and
seized huge chunks of land and gave it
to his veterans during the Civil War the
colonies generally sided with the
monarchy leading the English
Commonwealth to blockade some of them
Crom will briefly went to war with Spain
who ceded Jamaica which would form the
backbone of England sugar and slave
trades so long story short chromo died
in the monarchy was restored under
charles ii who in terms of empire
managed to gain new amsterdam from the
dutch which was swiftly renamed to new
york
the monarchy would soon find itself in
trouble again when Charles's son james a
second converted to Catholicism
Protestantism
was not too pleased about this and so
some lords asked the Dutch William of
Orange to become King of England which
he did in 1688 William's ascendancy to
the throne cost a major French supported
uprising in Ireland which was eventually
quashed Scotland also tried its hand at
colonisation during the period why
foundling Nova Scotia and modern-day
Canada which was quickly lost to the
French the most notorious attempt at
Scottish Empire building was the
founding of the colony at Caledonia and
what is now Panama in 1698 which was
claimed by Spain the colony failed due
to disease in a Spanish blockade and the
English refused to help because they
didn't want to provoke war
what makes Caledonia so notable was the
cost of its failure since the venture
had cost Scotland almost a fifth of its
national wealth and bankrupted the
kingdom thus the Scottish in English
empires at the turn of the 18th century
looked like this
in return for England financing
Scotland's debts both kingdoms were
unified by the 1707 act of Union which
gave birth to Great Britain Great
Britain immediately found itself caught
up in numerous European Wars from the
War of the Spanish Succession Britain
gained Gibraltar in southern Spain and
large swaths of French territory in
Canada next came the War of the Austrian
succession which wasn't very important
to Empire except that it paved the way
for a much more important war the Seven
Years War the Seven Years War was a
global conflict which saw British
victory and saw the transfer of a great
deal of North American territory to
Britain from France and Spain it should
be noted here that for many of these
countries the wars were nothing more
than excuses to seize each other's
territories the war also spread to India
where the British and French were trying
to squeeze each other out the reason for
this was the trade with India was
incredibly lucrative it focused mainly
on textile spices and the most important
consumer good of all time T so by the
beginning of the Seven Years War the
East India Company had already
established factories along the
coastline of India much of which was
controlled by either the Mughal or
Maratha empires the company was largely
independent and even had its own
military the company was also deeply
involved in Indian politics and were
very good at playing Indian Lords called
Nawabs off of each other for British
benefit robert clive also known as clive
of india led the East India Company
forces there the British won a decisive
victory against the Indians at the
Battle of Plassey he mostly due to some
double-dealing after defeating the
French the Dutch and later the Mughals
British territory in India looked like
this
Bengal was particularly important since
had a taxable population twice the size
of Britain after the Wars the company
began to levy heavy
is against the Localism bengal quickly
became an extremely important revenue
stream for britain robert clive was for
a short period the governor of Bengal
and one of his policies was to force
local farmers to grow opium for export
to China instead of food which meant
that whenever crops failed large numbers
of Bengali people starved Britain's
colonial successes in India were
contrasted by its failings in north
america the number of soldiers tax
disputes and lack of representation in
the British Parliament led the 13
colonies to declare their independence
the Americans were led by General George
Washington who would later become the
first President of the United States of
America Britain at first was able to win
some major victories but after years of
attrition alongside the French and
Spanish aiding the Americans the British
accepted American independence and lost
all of this territory the birth of the
British Empire was a slow and drawn-out
process the reasons for Cloney expansion
were diverse ranging from religious
calling to the desire for wealth
colonial failure led to the creation of
Great Britain but colonial success meant
the warfare now had a global scope and
it became increasingly difficult for the
rest of the world to stay uninvolved
from European politics I hope you
enjoyed this video and thank you for
watching